لذلك تقول في الواقع أن التضخم ليس
تهديدًا لأنه موجود بالفعل ، لذا
فإليك السؤال الكبير إلى متى سيستمر
التضخم ،
بالتأكيد هذا سؤال رائع
بالتأكيد طالما أن الوباء
مستعر ،
فسنرى أسعار معينة باقية
من المؤكد أن أسعار السلع
المرتفعة ستظل مرتفعة أيضًا
لأننا نرى افتتاحات إعادة فتح الخدمات
مثل
المطاعم والفنادق ، سترتفع هذه
الأسعار أيضًا نظرًا لحقيقة أن
لدينا نقصًا حادًا في اليد العاملة
وتتطلع الشركات إلى رفع الأجور
لجذب العمال  لذلك من
المحتمل أن تظل هذه الأشياء معنا حتى يصبح
الوباء وراءنا بشكل واضح ، ولكن
هناك أيضًا بعض ضغوط الأسعار الأخرى
التي ربما لن تختفي
بالتأكيد عندما نفكر في
نقص أشباه الموصلات الذي يضع
ضغطًا كبيرًا على الأدوات والسيارات
والأجهزة  وكذلك مجرد
التفكير في أسواق الإسكان الساخنة وبالتأكيد
يتطلع الكثير من جيل الألفية إلى شراء
منازل وكذلك الأشخاص الذين يتطلعون إلى الإقامة  في
المنزل لأنهم يعملون من المنزل ، وبالتالي
نتوقع أن تظل هذه الأسعار
مرتفعة أيضًا لفترة
أطول ،
هل تعتقد أنه بمجرد ارتفاع معدلات الرهن العقاري على
الرغم من أنها ترتفع الآن بعد أن
ازدهار الإسكان أو نقص المساكن لديهم
،  التراجع قليلاً
نعم من المحتمل أن ترى بعض
التقلبات هناك أه ولكن عندما تفكر في
ما يبحث عنه الفيدراليون فيما
يتعلق برفع الأسعار ، فإنهم لا
يتطلعون إلى رفع الأسعار على
المدى الطويل إلى أربعة أو خمسة  في المائة ،
ربما ننظر إلى اثنين وربع
اثنين ونصف في المائة ، لذا حتى
عندما تتناول ما يعنيه ذلك بالنسبة
لمعدلات الرهن العقاري ، ستظل معدلات الرهن العقاري
منخفضة جدًا وستظل القدرة على تحمل التكاليف
مرتفعة لكثير من الناس ،
لذا بشكل عام كما ترى
أثر التضخم على الانتعاش الاقتصادي
جيدًا ، كما تعلم الآن ، يبدو
أن المستهلكين لا يزالون في الخارج
ينفقون ، وأي تباطؤ
رأيناه في الإنفاق كان
نتيجة لمتغير دلتا  حيث
كان الناس مثل آه ، ربما لن أخرج
إلى مطعم أو أذهب في إجازة في الوقت الحالي ،
لكن ما زلنا ننظر إلى السلع التي
يدفعها الناس للمال مقابل الأشياء
طالما أن المخزونات
والشركات التجارية قادرة على إبقاء الرفوف
توقفها  يبدو أن الناس على
استعداد للإنفاق